Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. One that April, with his sure assault, the draught of March hath perished into the road, and bathed every vein, and switched liquor, of which virtue engendered is the floor. What is this accent? One Zephyrus Eke, with his sweet breath,
感谢您收听《历史余温》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。四月，带着它那确凿的侵袭，三月的干旱已消逝在路上，滋润了每一条脉络，那充满活力的甘露，其美德孕育了大地。这是什么口音？那西风神，带着他甜美的气息，
inspired hath in every halt and heath The tenderer croppers and the younger son, Hath in the ram his half a coarser run, And smaller fowlers make a melody That sleep in early night with open ye. So pricketh him that you're in here courages, That long on folk to go on pilgrimages, And palmers for the sake in stranger sons
在每一处灌木丛和荒野中激发出，更柔嫩的嫩芽和年轻的太阳，在白羊座中走完了他的一半路程，小鸟们也唱起了歌，它们在清晨睁着眼入睡。这激励着人们去朝圣，而那些棕榈树朝圣者，为了陌生人的缘故
To fern alvers, couther in sundry lawns And specially from every shire's end Of Angerland To counterbraid their wind The holy blissful matter of for to seek That hem hath holpen When the day worth seek That was brilliantly read dominic so as every british or english school child will know that is the opening the beautiful opening
前往各地的蕨类植物，在各种草坪上，特别是从安格尔兰的每一个郡的尽头，去对抗他们的风，去寻找那神圣而幸福的物质，当日子值得寻找时，那些帮助过他们的人。多米尼克读得太精彩了，正如每一位英国学童所知，那是杰弗里·乔叟所著《坎特伯雷故事集》的开篇，那美丽的开篇。
to the canterbury tales by jeffrey chaucer and tom one of the great passages in english literature yeah and you did wonderful credit to it. And let's be honest, nobody knows what it means. Some people do. Well. So Neville Coghill did, who was the great scholar who translated it for the Penguin Classics. Yeah. Which I originally gave you to read. Yeah.
汤姆，这是英国文学中最伟大的段落之一。是的，你读得非常出色。老实说，没人知道它是什么意思。有些人知道。好吧。内维尔·科吉尔知道，他是那位伟大的学者，为企鹅经典丛书翻译了它。是的。我最初让你读的那本。是的。
But you said, no, full in. No. Let's go for the Middle English. Yeah. You've got to do it properly. We don't mess around with modern translations. I mean, I've been criticized for weird accents, but I thought that was a very weird accent. Yeah, but I mean, you're dissing our predecessors.
但你说，不，要完整的。不。我们要读中古英语。是的。你必须做得地道。我们不搞那些现代翻译。我的意思是，我因为奇怪的口音被批评过，但我认为那是一个非常奇怪的口音。是的，但我的意思是，你在贬低我们的前辈。
You're dissing our ancestors with that. Is that what they sounded like? That is how they sounded. Brilliant. There's a bit of Scandinavian in there, which people may have picked up on. A sort of Germanic. Yeah. That is the purest and most unadulterated Middle English, Tom.
你用那种口音在贬低我们的祖先。他们听起来是那样的吗？他们听起来就是那样。太棒了。里面有一点斯堪的纳维亚的味道，人们可能已经听出来了。一种日耳曼语。是的。那是纯正且未经掺杂的中古英语，汤姆。
Well, that's wonderful. So, Tom. Okay. most unadulterated middle English, Tom. Well, that's wonderful. So Chaucer, who was born in around 1342 and dies in 1400, his life covers pretty much the span of all the episodes that we've been doing on the Hundred Years' War. So the reign of Edward III and Richard II. So I thought we couldn't really do the reign of Richard II and not talk about Chaucer because he's such a massively significant figure. So the Canterbury Tales, I love it. I'm not going to lie. I do love it for reasons that perhaps we'll come to in a few minutes. You said that
好吧，那太棒了。所以，汤姆。好的。最纯正的中古英语，汤姆。好吧，那太棒了。那么乔叟，他出生于1342年左右，卒于1400年，他的一生几乎涵盖了我们一直在做的关于百年战争的所有剧集。也就是爱德华三世和理查二世的统治时期。所以我认为我们不能在不谈论乔叟的情况下谈论理查二世的统治，因为他是一个极其重要的人物。所以《坎特伯雷故事集》，我喜欢它。我不撒谎。我确实喜欢它，原因也许我们几分钟后会谈到。你说过
people study him in school. I mean, he's probably the one figure from the reigns of Edward III and Richard II who is still part of the curriculum, wouldn't you say? Well, he's the founding father of English literature. But he's also somebody, Tom, I think it's fair to say, and we might as well be honest with the listeners, the very mention of Chaucer's name generally leaves people pale with fear because he's got a formidable reputation. Basically, nobody knows what on earth it means. And people have been forced to do it in school. And they find it utterly intimidating and terrifying. But I'm confident that you're going to explain. I hope so. He is a fascinating person. The Canterbury
人们在学校里学习他。我的意思是，他可能是爱德华三世和理查二世统治时期唯一仍然在课程中的人物，你觉得呢？嗯，他是英国文学的奠基人。但汤姆，我认为公平地说，我们不妨对听众诚实一点，提到乔叟的名字通常会让人们脸色苍白，因为他有着令人敬畏的名声。基本上，没人知道它到底是什么意思。人们在学校里被迫学习它。他们觉得它非常令人生畏和可怕。但我相信你会解释的。我希望如此。他是一个迷人的人。《坎特伯雷
Tales is brilliant and really funny and exciting and interesting. And there is no better window onto medieval England than through Chaucer and his great poem. Is that right? So I think one thing just for people to kind of reset the gears in their head is that we think of him as being very old because he's kind of 14th century, so he is old. But he's also, in the context of the 14th century, very radical, very modern, very new. He is the guy who invents the word newfangledness. So he is newfangled. So just keep that in your mind. Try and think of him not as this venerable figure, but as someone who is at the absolute cutting edge of everything that is transformative in the 14th century, all the kind of the trends that we've been talking about. And so, as you
故事集》非常精彩，非常有趣、令人兴奋且引人入胜。没有比通过乔叟和他的伟大诗作更好的窗口来了解中世纪的英格兰了。是这样吗？所以我认为人们需要调整一下思维方式的一点是，我们认为他非常古老，因为他是14世纪的人，所以他确实很老。但在14世纪的背景下，他也非常激进、非常现代、非常新颖。他发明了“新奇”（newfangledness）这个词。所以他是新潮的。所以请记住这一点。试着不要把他看作是一个德高望重的人物，而是一个处于14世纪所有变革性事物最前沿的人，也就是我们一直在谈论的各种趋势。所以，正如你
said, I mean, he is kind of enshrined as the father of English literature, which makes him sound very patriarchal and forbidding. Literally in Westminster Abbey. Absolutely. So his tomb in Westminster Abbey, it provides the kind of nucleus around which Poet's Corner has grown up. But he is also, I think, as you suggested, a fascinating window onto all the themes and episodes that we've been talking about.
所说，我的意思是，他被奉为英国文学之父，这让他听起来非常家长式且令人望而生畏。他确实安葬在威斯敏斯特教堂。绝对是。所以他在威斯敏斯特教堂的墓地，构成了“诗人角”发展的核心。但我认为，正如你所暗示的那样，他也是我们一直在谈论的所有主题和事件的一个迷人窗口。
And he's a poet who has an immense significance for me. He's one of those writers who I read at a very kind of formative time, which was actually, I mean, not long ago, it was in the pandemic. Because in April, 2020, I was meant to be walking with my brother across the North Downs in Kent. So pretty much along the route that the pilgrims would have taken from London to Canterbury. We should say, we haven't really said what the Canterbury Tales is about. Basically, it's about a group of pilgrims who are going from London to Canterbury. So we would have been following in their footsteps. And then of course, the lockdown, it didn't happen. And so I started reading the Canterbury Tales instead. Because the backdrop was the pandemic, I was alert to all
他是一位对我意义重大的诗人。他是我在某种形成期阅读的作家之一，实际上，我的意思是，不久前，是在疫情期间。因为在2020年4月，我本打算和我的兄弟一起穿过肯特郡的北唐斯。所以几乎沿着朝圣者从伦敦到坎特伯雷的路线。我们应该说，我们还没有真正说过《坎特伯雷故事集》是关于什么的。基本上，它是关于一群朝圣者从伦敦前往坎特伯雷。所以我们本会追随他们的脚步。然后当然，封锁了，没去成。所以我开始读《坎特伯雷故事集》。因为背景是疫情，我注意到了所有
kinds of things that I hadn't really noticed before. So on the question of why the pilgrims are heading to Canterbury. Yeah, I think that was very clear from the readings, to be honest. Well, to Canterbury they went, the holy blissful martyr fought to seek, that hem hath holpen when that they were sick. So basically, the holy blissful martyr is Thomas Beckett and he's going to cure them. The shrine in Canterbury where he was murdered is celebrated for its miracles. And Chaucer actually had very good reason to hold Beckett in particular high regard. So he grew up in London in one of the parishes there of St. Martin Vintry that had an altar to St. Thomas.
我以前没真正注意到的事情。关于朝圣者为什么要前往坎特伯雷的问题。是的，老实说，从阅读中我很清楚。好吧，他们去了坎特伯雷，去寻找那神圣而幸福的殉道者，当他们生病时，他曾帮助过他们。所以基本上，那位神圣而幸福的殉道者是托马斯·贝克特，他要去治愈他们。坎特伯雷他被谋杀的神龛以其奇迹而闻名。乔叟确实有很好的理由对贝克特给予特别的尊重。因为他在伦敦的圣马丁温特里教区长大，那里有一个圣托马斯祭坛。
And as an adult, he was always kind of going on business from London to Calais. So he would have passed through Canterbury. He would undoubtedly know the shrine very, very well. And I think that in April 2020, when everyone is thinking, when is this pandemic going to end? When are we going to get a vaccine? All that kind of stuff. the idea of people looking for cures seemed much more resonant than it might have done earlier before the pandemic right and chaucer of course had himself lived through a pandemic that made covid look like the mirror split the black death which was the black death and so you know he's born in 1342, and the Black Death arrives in England in the summer of 1348. So he would have remembered that, six years old.
成年后，他总是因为生意从伦敦去加来。所以他肯定会经过坎特伯雷。他无疑非常非常了解那个神龛。我认为在2020年4月，当每个人都在想，这场疫情什么时候结束？我们什么时候能打上疫苗？所有这些事情时，人们寻找治愈方法的想法似乎比疫情前更具共鸣。没错，乔叟当然也经历过一场让新冠看起来像小儿科的疫情，那就是黑死病。所以你知道，他出生于1342年，黑死病在1348年夏天到达英格兰。所以他六岁时应该记得那件事。
Right. And notoriously, Chaucer is a Londoner, and it hits London very, very hard. So Chaucer's great-grandfather had kept a pub. His grandfather had been a wine merchant. His father was hugely significant in the London wine import business. In fact, so significant that he ends up doing it by appointment to the King. And it's because of that, that the Chaucer family dodge a bullet because they get sent to Southampton the year before the Black Death arrives. And even though obviously it's on the South Coast where the Black Death first appears and it definitely hits it, it doesn't hit Southampton and the towns along the South Coast as badly as London. And this may be what enables Chaucer to live, because pretty much all his relatives in London
没错。众所周知，乔叟是伦敦人，而黑死病对伦敦的打击非常非常严重。所以乔叟的曾祖父开过一家酒吧。他的祖父是葡萄酒商。他的父亲在伦敦葡萄酒进口行业非常重要。事实上，非常重要，以至于他最终成为了国王的指定供应商。正是因为这个原因，乔叟一家躲过了一劫，因为他们在黑死病到达的前一年被派往南安普顿。尽管显然黑死病首先出现在南海岸，而且它确实袭击了那里，但它对南安普顿和南海岸沿线城镇的打击并没有像对伦敦那样严重。这可能就是乔叟得以活下来的原因，因为他在伦敦的所有亲戚
are wiped out by the Black Death. And this, in fact, is the making of Chaucer, because his mother and his father both inherit substantial amounts of property as a result of all their relatives being killed and gives Chaucer a kind of a massive head start. So his parents end up very, very affluent. So that must be a scarring memory for him. And the Black Death keeps revisiting England throughout his life. And by the time, so in the reign of Richard II, that he comes to write the Canterbury Tales, it's endemic in London. I mean, London has kind of recovered. So we talked about this in the Peasants' Revolt episodes.
几乎都被黑死病消灭了。事实上，这成就了乔叟，因为他的母亲和父亲都因为所有亲戚的死亡而继承了大量的财产，这给了乔叟一个巨大的领先优势。所以他的父母最终非常非常富有。那对他来说一定是一个痛苦的记忆。黑死病在他的一生中不断地重访英格兰。到理查二世统治时期，他开始写《坎特伯雷故事集》时，它在伦敦已经成为地方性疾病。我的意思是，伦敦已经恢复了。所以我们在“农民起义”那一集中谈到了这一点。
You've got cranes everywhere and high rises and it's a booming city. But the plague is endemic and it is a constant background presence. And you wouldn't actually be able to tell that from the Canterbury Tales unless you were looking for it. So there are very few references to it. So in a tale that is told by a knight, you have the terrifying figure of Saturn who boasts that his very gaze, my looking is the father of pestilence, he said. And then there's, have you read the Pardoner's Tale? I don't think I have, Tom. I'm ashamed to say. So the Pardoner's Tale, there are three riotous friends and they're told news of a guy who's been killed. And there came a privy thief, men clipeth death, that in
到处都是起重机和高楼，这是一个繁荣的城市。但瘟疫是地方性的，它是一个持续的背景存在。除非你刻意寻找，否则你实际上无法从《坎特伯雷故事集》中看出来。所以很少有关于它的提及。在骑士讲述的一个故事中，有土星这个可怕的人物，他吹嘘说他的一瞥，“我的注视是瘟疫之父”，他说。还有，你读过《赦罪师的故事》吗？我想我没有，汤姆。我很惭愧。所以《赦罪师的故事》，有三个放荡的朋友，他们听到了一个被杀的人的消息。然后来了一个秘密的小偷，人们称之为死亡，他在
this country all the people slayeth. And with his spear he smote his herder too, and went his way without word is more. He hath a thousand slain this pestilence. So that's a description of one of the great cycles of the play coming. Yeah. I feel you're not leaning into the accent there, Tom, but apart from that, it's fine. I'm not. No, no. But I mean, if you want to redo it, maybe later. No, no, no. Okay. So the writers go in search of death to kill death and they get told that death is to be found under a tree and they go to this tree and there is a huge great chest of gold and they immediately forget about their search for death and they decide that one of them should go into town to get a cart so they can take away all the gold he goes into town decides that he's going to
这个国家杀死了所有人。他用长矛刺死了他的牧人，然后一声不吭地走了。他用瘟疫杀了一千人。所以那是对瘟疫大循环之一的描述。是的。我觉得你没有在那种口音上下功夫，汤姆，但除此之外，没问题。我没有。不，不。但我的意思是，如果你想重读，也许以后吧。不，不，不。好的。所以这些放荡的人去寻找死亡来杀死死亡，他们被告知死亡可以在一棵树下找到，他们走到这棵树下，那里有一个巨大的金箱子，他们立刻忘记了寻找死亡，他们决定其中一个人应该进城去弄一辆马车，这样他们就可以把所有的金子带走，他进城决定他要
poison his friends so get some wine put some poison and it goes back meanwhile the two friends have decided that they're going to kill the third guy and divide the money up between the two of them. They do that. They then drink the wine and they all die and death is found. So it's a brilliant story and made all the more kind of complex. And one of the reasons why Chaucer is a brilliant poet, that it teaches a tremendous moral. The partner is a kind of a preacher, but he's also a loathsome man. What he's doing is basically flogging off bogus relics. You know, He tells these stories and then he screws money out of people. Brilliant stuff. But it's also a story that is rooted in experience because this idea that people respond to plague by behaving in a riotous way, this is
毒死他的朋友们，所以弄了一些酒放了些毒药，然后回去了。与此同时，那两个朋友决定他们要杀死第三个人，然后把钱分给他们俩。他们照做了。然后他们喝了酒，他们都死了，死亡被找到了。所以这是一个精彩的故事，而且变得更加复杂。乔叟是一位杰出诗人的原因之一，就是它传达了一个巨大的道德教训。赦罪师是一个传教士，但他也是一个令人作呕的人。他所做的基本上是兜售伪造的圣物。你知道，他讲这些故事，然后从人们那里骗钱。精彩的东西。但这也是一个植根于经验的故事，因为这种人们通过放荡行为来应对瘟疫的想法，这
absolutely a given. The idea that wild living is a response to death. English moralists look at London in particular and say that wild living has been a theme of how they respond to the plague. Thomas Walsingham, who we talked about, he's one of the chroniclers of the Peasants' Revolt. He says of Londoners, of all people, they were the proudest, the most arrogant, the most greedy. So that idea that you respond to plague by behaving in a wild way, this is kind of rooted in lived reality. But of course, wild living isn't the only response to plague. There is also pilgrimage. And I think that this is the context for the whole motif of the Canterbury Tales. Because what happens is that Chaucer describes himself going to Southwark to a pub
绝对是一个既定事实。这种生活方式是对死亡的一种回应。英国的道德家们特别审视伦敦，说放荡的生活一直是他们应对瘟疫的一种主题。我们谈到的托马斯·沃尔辛厄姆，他是“农民起义”的编年史家之一。他谈到伦敦人时说，在所有人中，他们是最骄傲、最傲慢、最贪婪的。所以那种通过放荡行为来应对瘟疫的想法，这在某种程度上植根于现实生活。但当然，放荡的生活并不是应对瘟疫的唯一方式。还有朝圣。我认为这就是《坎特伯雷故事集》整个主题的背景。因为发生的事情是乔叟描述自己去萨瑟克的一家酒吧
called the Tabard. And he's going on pilgrimage. And while he's there, he meets with nine and 20 people, so 29 people, and they all meet up and they all agree that Chaucer will go with them and they will head off to Canterbury together. And this is the basis for all the stories that then follow. And it struck me when I was reading this in April, 2020, that this is exactly what we couldn't do. We couldn't meet up with people. We couldn't meet up with strangers in pubs. All the pubs were shut.
叫“塔巴德”。他要去朝圣。当他在那里时，他遇到了29个人，他们都聚在一起，他们都同意乔叟将和他们一起去，他们将一起前往坎特伯雷。这就是随后所有故事的基础。当我在2020年4月读到这一点时，我感到震惊，这正是我们无法做到的。我们无法与人见面。我们无法在酒吧里与陌生人见面。所有的酒吧都关门了。
You know, you had to socially distance. And that in a way, perhaps the Canterbury Tales is a celebration of getting out there and meeting new people and being able to travel. Because, you know, that famous, famous opening line, when thatil with his sure as zuta the sweet showers falling april is the month when the plague season ends in london so we know from the records of deathbed wills that january and february and march are the most lethal months for plague in london and in fact across northern europe and so april is when the plague ends. And even though people in the 14th century, they had no notion of germ theory, they absolutely had a sense that when plague hits, you should socially distance. So one of Chaucer's great inspirations for telling a series of short
你知道，你必须保持社交距离。在某种程度上，也许《坎特伯雷故事集》是对走出去、结识新朋友和能够旅行的一种庆祝。因为，你知道，那句著名、著名的开场白，当四月甜美的雨水落下时，四月是伦敦瘟疫季节结束的月份，所以我们从临终遗嘱的记录中知道，一月、二月和三月是伦敦乃至整个北欧瘟疫最致命的月份，所以四月是瘟疫结束的时候。尽管14世纪的人们没有细菌理论的概念，但他们绝对有一种感觉，当瘟疫来袭时，你应该保持社交距离。所以乔叟讲述一系列短篇故事的伟大灵感之一
stories is the Cameron by Boccaccio, the great Italian writer. And his kind of framing device is that the plague has hit Florence and people decide that they're going to retreat from Florence and kind of wall themselves up in a safe place in a garden where no one can get at them. So there is this sense that when plague hits, you isolate. I think the Canterbury Tales is the reverse of that. It's about saying, plague season is over. We can all meet up. Let's head out there. So in a sense, the Canterbury Tales is a great eulogy to the joys in a time of plague of meeting strangers and of not socially distancing. See, I actually enjoyed socially distancing and not meeting strangers, but that's by the
是意大利伟大作家薄伽丘的《十日谈》。他的框架设计是瘟疫袭击了佛罗伦萨，人们决定从佛罗伦萨撤退，把自己围在一个安全的地方，在一个没人能进去的花园里。所以有一种感觉，当瘟疫来袭时，你会隔离。我认为《坎特伯雷故事集》正好相反。它是关于说，瘟疫季节结束了。我们都可以见面了。让我们出发吧。所以从某种意义上说， 《坎特伯雷故事集》是对瘟疫时期结识陌生人和不保持社交距离的快乐的伟大颂歌。看，我实际上很享受社交距离和不结识陌生人，但那是题外话。
by. So you would have hated hanging out with the partner and the knight and everybody. I wouldn't have enjoyed that at all. Brilliant. But I think it's kind of interesting because it's one example of the way in which Chaucer's biography is repeatedly touching on all the great themes of the age.
所以你本会讨厌和赦罪师、骑士以及所有人混在一起。我一点也不会喜欢那样。精彩。但我认为这很有趣，因为它是乔叟的传记反复触及那个时代所有伟大主题的一个例子。
Remind us again when he was born? 1342, did you say? Around 1342. So he's right there with the ringside seat and the high point for England of the Hundred Years' War, right? He is. And when you say ringside seat,
再提醒我们一下他是什么时候出生的？1342年，你是这么说的吗？1342年左右。所以他就在那里，坐在前排，见证了英格兰百年战争的高潮，对吧？他是。当你说是前排座位时，
I mean, in some senses, literally, he's watching the great tournaments that Edward III is throwing to celebrate his victories because the wealth that his parents have accrued both by their own agency and because all their relatives have died and left them their property means that he is able to get social promotion. So as a young man, he is a page in the household of Lionel, who we mentioned in the previous episode. He's the third son of Edward III, the ancestor of Edmund of March, who should have legitimately succeeded Richard II. Chaucer is a page in his household, and he's, we know, tremendously stylish.
我的意思是，在某种意义上，字面上，他正在观看爱德华三世为庆祝胜利而举办的盛大锦标赛，因为他的父母通过自己的努力以及所有亲戚去世并留下财产而积累的财富，意味着他能够获得社会晋升。所以作为一个年轻人，他是莱昂内尔家庭的一名侍从，我们在上一集中提到过。他是爱德华三世的第三个儿子，是埃德蒙·莫蒂默的祖先，他本应合法地继承理查二世。乔叟是他家庭的一名侍从，我们知道他非常时髦。
So he's a guy who wears a paltok, which is a very short garment, which moralists, again, are very opposed to. They fail to conceal the arse of the person who wears it or their private parts. Is that a quotation? That is indeed a quotation. Nice to think of Chaucer sporting that as a young lad. Right. He's a witness to the golden age of the court of Edward III, and he goes on war with Edward. In 1359, he accompanies him on one of his great chevauchées, the one that ends up before Paris, and they don't manage to capture the city.
所以他是一个穿“帕尔托克”（paltok）的人，这是一种非常短的服装，道德家们再次强烈反对这种服装。它们无法遮住穿着者的屁股或私处。那是一句引语吗？那确实是一句引语。想到乔叟年轻时穿着那个样子真是太好了。没错。他是爱德华三世宫廷黄金时代的见证人，他随爱德华参加了战争。1359年，他陪同他进行了伟大的“骑行劫掠”（chevauchées）之一，那次行动最终到达巴黎城下，但他们没能占领这座城市。
So one of these raids, one of these kind of burning and pillaging raids. Yes. And in 1360, Chaucer is captured, and he ends up being ransomed for 15 pounds by Edward III himself. So he's witnessed the Hundred Years' War. He's witnessed both its glories and its horrors. And actually, the tale that is told by the knight, it's the first of the tales in the Canterbury Tales. There's a lot about captivity. There's a lot about the horrors of war. There's a lot about the kind of destruction and carnage that's inflicted about it. And I think that you get the sense both from Chaucer's poetry and from his career that he's not a great fan of fighting. He turns out to be a natural diplomat. So he goes on a lot of expeditions to places that, again, people who've listened to our series on the
所以这些袭击之一，这些烧杀抢掠的袭击之一。是的。1360年，乔叟被俘，最终被爱德华三世本人以15英镑赎回。所以他见证了百年战争。他见证了它的荣耀和恐怖。事实上，骑士讲述的故事，是《坎特伯雷故事集》中的第一个故事。里面有很多关于囚禁的内容。有很多关于战争恐怖的内容。有很多关于它所造成的破坏和杀戮的内容。我认为你从乔叟的诗歌和他的职业生涯中都能感觉到，他不是一个好战的人。他最终成为了一名天生的外交官。所以他去了很多地方，同样，听过我们关于
Hundred Years' War will recognize. So he goes to Navarre, the home of Charles the Bad, brilliantly named Charles the Bad. And he goes to Italy a lot. Very, very influential on his development as a poet, because Italy at this point is a place where poets like Dante would be the most celebrated example, are starting to write in their own language rather than in Latin. And this, of course, is what Chaucer will do. So it's often said that Chaucer is writing in English, perhaps because he's hostile to foreign influences. He's a kind of literary Brexit or something like that. Yeah.
百年战争系列节目的听众会认出来。所以他去了纳瓦拉，查理恶人（Charles the Bad）的家乡，名字起得真好，查理恶人。他经常去意大利。对他作为诗人的发展非常有影响力，因为当时的意大利是一个像但丁这样最著名的例子，开始用自己的语言而不是拉丁语写作的地方。当然，这就是乔叟要做的事情。所以人们常说乔叟用英语写作，也许是因为他敌视外国影响。他是一种文学上的脱欧派之类的。是的。
He's a literary Farageist. He's actually very Romain. Right. Because he's writing in English because he's being influenced by continental styles. So that's what he's trying to do. Yeah. Yeah.
他是一个文学上的法拉奇主义者。他实际上非常亲罗马。没错。因为他用英语写作是因为他受到了大陆风格的影响。所以这就是他试图做的。是的。是的。
He's a very cosmopolitan, very well connected man. So he's cosmopolitan both because he's traveled on the continent, but also the reason he's been sent on the continent is because he can speak Italian because he's grown up in one of the most cosmopolitan wards in London. It's full of Italian merchants, Flemish merchants. He's having daily dealings with them. So he speaks, you know, obviously he can speak French, he can speak Latin. He's very, very kind of sophisticated, but he's also well connected because, you know, he's been a page in. He's very, very sophisticated. But he's also well-connected because he's been a page in Lionel's court, but he also ends up amazingly with a family relationship to John
他是一个非常国际化、人脉非常广的人。所以他之所以国际化，既是因为他去过欧洲大陆，也是因为他被派往欧洲大陆的原因是他会说意大利语，因为他在伦敦最国际化的街区之一长大。那里到处都是意大利商人、佛兰芒商人。他每天都与他们打交道。所以他会说，你知道，显然他会说法语，他会说拉丁语。他非常非常世故，但他的人脉也很广，因为，你知道，他曾是莱昂内尔宫廷的侍从。他非常非常世故。但他的人脉也很广，因为他曾是莱昂内尔宫廷的侍从，而且他最终还与约翰·冈特有亲戚关系。
of Gaunt. So the most powerful magnate, yeah. Towering figure. So amazingly, his sister-in-law, who comes from Hainaut, like Philippa, who marries Edward III, his sister-in-law ends up marrying John of Gaunt and becoming the Duchess of Lancaster. So Chaucer, from this very humble background, has a kind of very distant family link to the great man. And when he's traveling to Italy, he's doing it as John of Gaunt's agent. And this is embroiling him in London politics, because again, I mean, looking back to the Peasants' Revolt episode, John of Gaunt is unpopular because he is basically hawking off licenses to Italian merchants and to
所以是最强大的权贵，是的。高耸的人物。所以令人惊讶的是，他的嫂子，来自埃诺，就像嫁给爱德华三世的菲利帕一样，他的嫂子最终嫁给了约翰·冈特，成为了兰开斯特公爵夫人。所以乔叟，从这个非常卑微的背景，与这位大人物有了一种非常遥远的家庭联系。当他前往意大利时，他是作为约翰·冈特的代理人去的。这使他卷入了伦敦的政治，因为同样，回顾“农民起义”那一集，约翰·冈特之所以不受欢迎，是因为他基本上在向意大利商人和
Lombard merchants and to Fleming merchants, allowing them to participate in the wool trade or whatever, because he's trying to raise money for the crown. And this is hugely opposed by monopolists in London who want to keep the wool trade entirely for themselves. So Chaucer is siding with John of Gaunt. And remember, Tom, in the President's Revolt, mobs attacking Lombards and stuff, Flemings. There was the sense of xenophobia. And he's on the wrong side of that from the point of view of the London mob, isn't he, Chaucer? Right. And in 1374, he is appointed controller of the wool custom, which basically means that,
伦巴第商人以及佛兰芒商人兜售许可证，允许他们参与羊毛贸易之类的，因为他试图为王室筹集资金。这遭到了伦敦垄断者的强烈反对，他们想把羊毛贸易完全留给自己。所以乔叟站在约翰·冈特一边。记住，汤姆，在“农民起义”中，暴徒袭击伦巴第人等等，佛兰芒人。有一种仇外心理。从伦敦暴徒的角度来看，乔叟站在了错误的一边，不是吗？没错。1374年，他被任命为羊毛关税主管，这基本上意味着，
you know, I mean, he's the man responsible for organizing the entire kind of wool trade from London to the continent. And he does it brilliantly. I mean, he's clearly an amazingly effective civil servant and kind of operator. So he holds the job for over a decade. And, you know, kind of reading about what his life, so there's a wonderful biography by Marian Turner, Chaucer, A European Life. She gives a brilliant portrait of Chaucer as in his role as controller of the wool custom. And there's kind of something weirdly modern about him. Again, this idea that Chaucer is a kind of hinge between the medieval and the modern. So he has this grace and favour apartment above Aldgate, which is literally one of the Roman gates in the city
你知道，我的意思是，他是负责组织从伦敦到欧洲大陆整个羊毛贸易的人。他做得非常出色。我的意思是，他显然是一位非常高效的公务员和操作者。所以他担任这个职位超过十年。而且，你知道，读到关于他生活的事情，玛丽安·特纳有一本精彩的传记，《乔叟，欧洲生活》。她出色地描绘了乔叟作为羊毛关税主管的角色。他身上有一种奇怪的现代感。同样，这种乔叟是中世纪和现代之间枢纽的想法。所以他在奥尔德门（Aldgate）上方有一个恩惠公寓，这实际上是城市城墙的罗马城门之一。
walls. And he has this kind of flat basically above the gate. And his place of work is an office near the tower. And so he's walking to work. So he's commuting. And this is very, very unusual. People don't normally do this. So he's one of the very earliest London commuters that we know of. Did you not want to call this episode the first commuter? Well, I thought it might be. I think that it gives him a kind of vividness, a sense of the contemporaneous that perhaps otherwise he wouldn't have. I have to say that has gone on the honours board of mad Tom Holland ideas. But anyway, continue.
他基本上住在城门上方。他的工作地点是塔楼附近的一个办公室。所以他步行上班。所以他在通勤。这非常非常不寻常。人们通常不会这样做。所以他是我们所知的最早的伦敦通勤者之一。你不想把这一集命名为“第一个通勤者”吗？嗯，我以为可能会。我认为这给了他一种生动感，一种同时代的感觉，否则他可能不会有。我必须说，这已经进入了疯狂汤姆·霍兰德想法的荣誉榜。但无论如何，继续。
But it is a dangerous job because he is in the crosshairs of this venomous rivalry between the monopolists in London, between John of Gaunt. And also, it has to be said that he has some quite unsavoury associates. So one of his family associates is Sir Richard Lyons, again, who we mentioned in the Peasants' Revolt episode, who was a fabulously corrupt associate of John of Gaunt. He was a whiner rather than a wool monopolist. And he comes to a very, very sticky end in the Peasants' Revolt. So not only is Gaunt's sack, but Sir Richard Lyons is dragged out from his house and has his head chopped off by a mob on Cheapside in the heart of the city. And so you have to wonder, how close did Chaucer come
但这是一项危险的工作，因为他处于伦敦垄断者和约翰·冈特之间这种恶毒竞争的十字准线上。而且，必须说他有一些相当令人不快的伙伴。所以他的家庭伙伴之一是理查德·里昂爵士，同样，我们在“农民起义”那一集中提到过，他是约翰·冈特一个极其腐败的伙伴。他是一个葡萄酒商，而不是羊毛垄断者。他在“农民起义”中下场非常非常惨。所以不仅冈特被洗劫，理查德·里昂爵士也被暴徒从家中拖出来，在城市中心的奇普赛德被砍下了头。所以你不得不怀疑，乔叟离被撕成碎片有多近？因为他绝对是在城市的风暴中心。
to being torn to pieces? Because he's absolutely in the eye of the city. And so you have to wonder, how close did Chaucer come to being torn to pieces? Because he's absolutely in the eye of the storm. So think about that flat above the Aldgate. The Aldgate is the gate through which the rebels from Essex and Suffolk come flooding into the city. So we don't know if Chaucer is there. Yeah, hiding in the back room. But if he was, I mean, it must the back room. by a fox and there's this great kind of turmoil all the hens kind of flying up startled so hideous was the noise god bless us all jack straw and all his followers in their brawl were never half so shrill for all their noise when they were murdering those flemish boys as that day's hue and cry upon
所以你不得不怀疑，乔叟离被撕成碎片有多近？因为他绝对是在风暴中心。所以想想奥尔德门上方的那个公寓。奥尔德门是来自埃塞克斯和萨福克的叛军涌入城市的城门。所以我们不知道乔叟是否在那里。是的，躲在后屋里。但如果他在那里，我的意思是，那一定是被狐狸惊动了，那种巨大的骚乱，所有的母鸡都惊慌失措地飞起来，声音是多么可怕，上帝保佑我们所有人，杰克·斯特劳和他的所有追随者在他们的争吵中，当他们谋杀那些佛兰芒男孩时，他们的声音从来没有像那天对狐狸的叫喊声那样尖锐。
the fox so you have there both the din and a kind of sense of horror at the murder of the Flemings who were part of a basically a kind of mass lynching and it kind of sounds personal I mean it's kind of sounds like it's coming from maybe something he'd observed we don't know but what we do know for sure is that basically Chaucer survives it yeah and I think he is a survivor he's a man with a kind of a genius for negotiating the rapids of the age. And maybe something of Shakespeare in that, do you think? Shakespeare also, I mean, he seems to be a kind of smooth operator. Right.
所以你既听到了喧闹声，也感受到了一种对谋杀佛兰芒人的恐惧，他们基本上是一场大规模私刑的一部分，这听起来很个人化，我的意思是，这听起来像是来自他观察到的东西，我们不知道，但我们确定的是，乔叟基本上幸存了下来。是的，我认为他是一个幸存者，他是一个有天赋的人，能够驾驭时代的急流。你认为莎士比亚身上也有这种特质吗？莎士比亚也是，我的意思是，他似乎是一个圆滑的操作者。没错。
Yeah. Well, I mean, to keep his head in turbulent times, I mean, not just the Black Death, but as you say, the Peasants' Revolt, he must have had something about him. But also the fact that he's taken up by powerful people. You would never thrive in medieval court if you were a kind of difficult, prickly, unimpressive person. Yeah. So I think he's very kind of emollient, very diplomatic.
是的。好吧，我的意思是，要在动荡时期保住脑袋，我的意思是，不仅仅是黑死病，正如你所说，还有“农民起义”，他一定有他的过人之处。而且他被有权势的人看中这一事实。如果你是一个困难、棘手、平庸的人，你永远不会在中世纪宫廷中茁壮成长。是的。所以我认为他非常温和，非常外交。
He's clearly very charming, I guess. I mean, he keeps people on side. When he speaks foreign languages, he's used to dealing with foreign bigwigs, all of that sort of business. So you do get some sense of him, don't you? Yeah. But because he's been through the Hundred Years' War, the plague, peasants' revolt, all the convulsions of the age, he is very aware that he's living through effectively a period of
我想他显然非常有魅力。我的意思是，他让人们站在他这一边。当他说外语时，他习惯于与外国大人物打交道，所有这些事情。所以你确实对他有了一些了解，不是吗？是的。但因为他经历了百年战争、瘟疫、农民起义，经历了那个时代所有的动荡，他非常清楚自己实际上生活在一个
social and cultural transformation. And he himself is an embodiment of that because he's the grandson of a pub landlord who is now a relative of the Duke of Lancaster. So he's aware that it's a period where traditional hierarchies are being upended. And again, that idea of people meeting up from all walks of life in the Tabard Inn and preparing to go on pilgrimage, if this is signaling an escape from plague, from a period of social distancing through the winter, I think it is also signaling a society in flux. And I'm sure that that's why Chaucer chooses the framing device he does. It's an opportunity for bringing people from all different walks of life together. And this is also what is newfangled, to use Chaucer's own word, his own neologism. It's what's newfangled about
社会和文化转型的时期。他本人就是这种转型的化身，因为他是酒吧老板的孙子，现在是兰开斯特公爵的亲戚。所以他意识到这是一个传统等级制度被颠覆的时期。同样，人们在塔巴德旅馆聚在一起，准备去朝圣的想法，如果这标志着逃离瘟疫，逃离冬季社交距离的时期，我认为这也标志着一个处于动荡中的社会。我相信这就是乔叟选择他所使用的框架的原因。这是一个将来自各行各业的人聚集在一起的机会。这也是“新奇的”，用乔叟自己的话来说，他自己的新造词。这就是《坎特伯雷故事集》的“新奇”之处，
the Canterbury Tales, because it's a poem that is embracing multiple perspectives, men, women, from an incredible array of social backgrounds. And there's been nothing like it in English literature, in any kind of document or record that we have from medieval England before. So to quote Marian Turner, who's brilliant on this, characters from ordinary life who talk about themselves and their own experiences in detail, narrating personal histories and encouraging sympathetic responses and identifications. And I read her book very shortly, Dominic, after I read your book on the early 80s, Who Dares Wins. What I loved about Who Dares Wins, I loved loads about it, but I loved the social richness of it. Oh, that's nice.
因为它是一首拥抱多种视角的诗，男人、女人，来自令人难以置信的社会背景。在英国文学中，在我们在中世纪英格兰拥有的任何文件或记录中，从来没有过这样的东西。所以引用玛丽安·特纳的话，她对此非常精辟，来自普通生活的人物详细谈论他们自己和他们自己的经历，叙述个人历史并鼓励同情的反应和认同。多米尼克，我在读完你关于80年代初的书《谁敢赢》后不久就读了她的书。我喜欢《谁敢赢》的一点是，我喜欢它很多地方，但我喜欢它的社会丰富性。哦，那太好了。
The way in which people from every walk of life, you talk about the royal family and you talk about unemployed people and you talk about football and you talk about new romantics and you talk about snooker and everything is there. You love the snooker. And I was kind of thinking that the Canterbury Tales, basically, it's a prefiguring of that understanding of society as being inherently interesting in all its complexity and richness. Yeah. But he's not, you know, we're not the rest is literature, but he's significant, I think, because his poetry enables us for the first time, if you like, to write a kind of Sandbrookian history. So that comparison with Geoffrey Chaucer, Tom, has dogged me all my life, to be honest. But do you think, would you recognize? I hadn't thought of the comparison with myself, it's fair to say.
人们来自各行各业的方式，你谈论王室，你谈论失业者，你谈论足球，你谈论新浪漫主义，你谈论斯诺克，一切都在那里。你喜欢斯诺克。我当时在想，《坎特伯雷故事集》，基本上，它是对那种理解社会在所有复杂性和丰富性中本质上是有趣的预演。是的。但他不是，你知道，我们不是“文学余温”，但他很重要，我认为，因为他的诗歌使我们第一次，如果你愿意的话，能够写出一种桑德布鲁克式的历史。所以那个与杰弗里·乔叟的比较，汤姆，老实说，困扰了我一生。但你认为，你会认出来吗？我不得不说，我没想过和自己比较。
I'm not saying, just to be clear, I'm not comparing you as a literary figure with Chaucer. Oh, that's disappointing. But the reason the Canterbury Tales is fascinating from the historian's point of view, I think, is that you get ordinary people, you could call them ordinary people. Yeah. It's a panorama of a kind that has never previously existed, right? Yes. It's a social mosaic. And I'm just thinking whether there is any precedent for it,
我不是说，为了清楚起见，我不是在把你作为一个文学人物与乔叟进行比较。哦，那太令人失望了。但从历史学家的角度来看，《坎特伯雷故事集》之所以引人入胜，是因为你得到了普通人，你可以称他们为普通人。是的。这是一个前所未有的全景，对吧？是的。这是一个社会马赛克。我只是在想是否有任何先例，
whether there is anything like it. I don't think there is. Certainly not in English. And I don't really think in other literatures either. Okay. So that's Chaucer. And maybe in the second half, Tom, we can get into the Canterbury Tales a little bit. Because as you said, we're not the rest of literature. But the point of the Canterbury Tales is not just that it's a magnificent work of literary craftsmanship, but it's an incredible historical document. Yeah.
是否有任何类似的东西。我不认为有。当然不是用英语。我也不认为在其他文学作品中也有。好的。这就是乔叟。也许在下半场，汤姆，我们可以稍微深入了解一下《坎特伯雷故事集》。因为正如你所说，我们不是“文学余温”。但《坎特伯雷故事集》的重点不仅在于它是一部宏伟的文学工艺作品，而且它是一份令人难以置信的历史文献。是的。
And so we'll tease out some of that after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
所以休息后我们会梳理出其中的一些内容。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Lordings, quoth he, now hearken for the best, but take it not, I pray you, in disdain. This is the point, to speak it blatant plain,
一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开了娱乐业的帷幕，告诉您它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。领主们，他说，现在听好了，为了最好的，但请不要轻视它。重点是，直白地说，
that each of you to shorten with your way in this voyage shall tellen tale as twa to Canterbury would, I mean it so, and home would he shall tell another two of adventurers that Willam have before, and which of you that beareth him best of all, that is to say, that telleth in this case tale as a best sentence, and most so lace shall have a supper at y'all a cost, here in this sitting by this post when that ye come again from Canterbury. Who knows what it means? Tom, you know what it means.
你们每个人为了缩短旅途，在这次航行中都应该讲一个故事，就像去坎特伯雷一样，我是认真的，回家时他应该再讲两个关于冒险的故事，你们中谁表现得最好，也就是说，在这种情况下讲的故事最有意义，最有趣，谁就会在你们从坎特伯雷回来时，在这里坐在这根柱子旁，享用一顿由大家买单的晚餐。谁知道这是什么意思？汤姆，你知道这是什么意思。
Well, what does it mean? You give the translation. So basically the deal is this. They've met in that Tabard, a pub, haven't they? Yeah, in Selak. And the guy who's the host has said to them you know you've got this pilgrimage you're going to go on this massive expedition to canterbury very tom holland behavior and each of you will tell stories to each isn't that right to each on the way out yeah to each on the way back
好吧，这是什么意思？你来翻译一下。所以基本上交易是这样的。他们在那个塔巴德酒吧见面了，不是吗？是的，在萨瑟克。那个作为主持人的家伙对他们说，你知道你们有这次朝圣，你们要进行这次大规模的坎特伯雷远征，非常汤姆·霍兰德的行为，你们每个人都会给对方讲故事，不是吗？去的时候给对方讲，是的，回来的时候给对方讲，
yeah and it'll pass the time but it's also a competition because when we all get back to canterbury the person who is told the best stories by sort of popular acclamation- Well, no, the host will decide. Yeah, but he'll presumably take the temperature of the company, Tom. Of course, of course, yes. Everybody, they will all contribute and they will buy dinner for the person who's done the best job. And that's the fun of it. It's a game. It's a contest. Exactly. And this idea of people speaking in succession from different walks of society,
是的，这会打发时间，但这也是一场比赛，因为当我们回到坎特伯雷时，那个通过某种大众欢呼讲出最好故事的人——好吧，不，主持人会决定。是的，但他大概会观察大家的反应，汤姆。当然，当然，是的。每个人，他们都会做出贡献，他们会为做得最好的人买晚餐。这就是乐趣所在。这是一个游戏。这是一场比赛。完全正确。这种人们来自社会不同阶层依次发言的想法，
I think someone in the late 14th century reading this would automatically assume that it would go on to express what is the absolutely traditional kind of medieval love of hierarchy and formality. The idea that everyone has his station, his or her station, and that therefore the ordering of the tales should reflect that. So the setup is given us, the pilgrims are going to Canterbury, they're accompanied by the host, there's a guy called Harry Bailey, and they draw lots. And the first person to tell a tale is the guy who is the most socially significant, who is the knight, who we've already mentioned. And he then tells a very traditional chivalric romance.
我认为14世纪末读到这一点的人会自动认为它会继续表达那种绝对传统的中世纪对等级制度和形式的喜爱。每个人都有自己的位置，他或她的位置，因此故事的顺序应该反映这一点。所以设定已经给了我们，朝圣者们要去坎特伯雷，他们由主持人陪同，有一个叫哈里·贝利的人，他们抽签。第一个讲故事的人是社会地位最高的人，也就是骑士，我们已经提到过他。然后他讲了一个非常传统的骑士浪漫故事。
And I think that people would think, okay, we know where we're going with this. It's going to go from the highest to the lowest. But right from the beginning, everything is basically jumbled. And even before the knight starts his tale, you're aware that things aren't quite as you, if you're a guy in the 14th century, as you would expect. So first of all, the division between fiction and reality is being blurred. So Harry Bailey, the host, he actually exists. He's not a fictional character. We have over 20 contemporary records that name him. He's not specifically linked to the tabard, but we know that he was an austere, an innkeeper in Southwark. So he probably did
我想人们会认为，好吧，我们知道这故事要往哪儿发展了。它会从最高贵的人讲到最卑微的人。但从一开始，一切基本上就是混乱的。甚至在骑士开始讲他的故事之前，你就已经意识到，如果你是一个14世纪的人，事情并不像你预期的那样。首先，虚构与现实之间的界限正在变得模糊。哈里·贝利（Harry Bailey），也就是旅店主人，他是真实存在的。他不是虚构人物。我们有超过20份同时代的记录提到了他的名字。他虽然没有明确与塔巴德（Tabard）旅店挂钩，但我们知道他是一位严谨的萨瑟克（Southwark）旅店老板。所以他很可能
run and own the tabard. And he was also an MP. So he's a significant figure. And Chaucer knows him. Chaucer does know him. Yes. And this must be a tremendous joke. Yes. Maybe an in-joke between the two of them. Yes. And all their circle people in London. He's probably a well-known London character. I mean, he's an MP. He's a big landlord in in southwark and of course the other real person
经营并拥有塔巴德旅店。而且他还是位国会议员。所以他是个重要人物。乔叟认识他。乔叟确实认识他。是的。这一定是个巨大的笑话。是的。也许是他们两人之间的一个内部笑话。是的。还有他们在伦敦的所有圈内人。他可能是一个伦敦知名的角色。我的意思是，他是一位国会议员。他是萨瑟克的大地主，当然，诗中出现的另一个真实人物
who's in the poem is chaucer himself but it's kind of chaucer and it's kind of not because chaucer has to tell a tale and he's terrible his tale is so bad that the host stops it right yeah so he tells a tale of a knight called satopaz. So one of the descriptions of Sir Topaz, he had a seemly nose. Very good. And the host just said, this is terrible. Stop it. Right. And then Chaucer tells another story and it's incredibly boring. And it's that sense that
就是乔叟本人，但这有点像是乔叟，又有点不像，因为乔叟必须讲一个故事，但他讲得很烂，他的故事太糟糕了，以至于旅店主人不得不打断他。没错。所以他讲了一个关于托帕兹爵士（Sir Topaz）的骑士故事。关于托帕兹爵士的描述之一是，他有一个端正的鼻子。非常好。而旅店主人只是说，这太糟糕了。停下。没错。然后乔叟讲了另一个故事，简直无聊透顶。那种感觉就是
we're not just in a fictional world. We are in a world where a mirror is being held up to reality and distorting it. So Tom, it's like Curb Your Enthusiasm with Larry David. Yeah, that's exactly what it's like. Chaucer is Larry David. Yeah. That's exactly what it's like. Brilliant comparison.
我们不仅仅是在一个虚构的世界里。我们身处的世界就像一面照向现实并将其扭曲的镜子。所以汤姆，这就像拉里·大卫（Larry David）的《抑制热情》（Curb Your Enthusiasm）。是的，完全就是那样。乔叟就是拉里·大卫。是的。完全就是那样。精彩的类比。
But of course, more significantly and intriguingly, the social hierarchy is blurred. So as I say, you begin with the knight and classically in the medieval understanding of society, it's tripartite. So you have those who fight, those who pray, those who labor. And in the Canterbury Tales, you do get kind of representative figures for those three classes of person. So of course you have the knight, you have a parson, and you have a ploughman. And the ploughman is the brother of the parson. And Chaucer seems to admire all three. Terry Jones famously wrote a book arguing that actually the knight was an evil mercenary, but I think that's generally not
但当然，更重要且耐人寻味的是，社会等级制度变得模糊了。正如我所说，你从骑士开始，在经典的中古社会理解中，它是三方的。即：祈祷者、作战者、劳作者。在《坎特伯雷故事集》中，你确实得到了这三个阶层的代表人物。当然，你有骑士、牧师和农夫。农夫是牧师的兄弟。乔叟似乎对这三者都很钦佩。特里·琼斯（Terry Jones）曾写过一本书，论证说骑士实际上是个邪恶的雇佣兵，但我认为这通常不被
accepted. The knight is a figure of chivalry and prowess. He's a very perfect, gentle knick, is the famous Chaucerian phrase. The parson is a person who is unlike a lot of the clerical figures. So like the partner, like the summoner, like the monk, all of whom are kind of corrupt in various ways. The prioress, who is a shocking anti-Semite. The parson is an admirable figure. And the ploughman, likewise, is a person who's very close to Christ. So he seems to respect all three. But he understands that that paradigm is inadequate to explain the complexities of the society in which he is living. He's a Londoner. He's witnessed how complex society is. He also has personal experience of the way in which attempts to impose traditional old-fashioned hierarchies on society simply don't work. So in the first episode, we talked about the statute of labourers.
接受。骑士是骑士精神和勇武的象征。他是“一位完美、温文尔雅的骑士”，这是乔叟那句名言。牧师是一个与许多教士形象不同的人。比如赦罪师、传令官、僧侣，他们都在不同程度上有些腐败。女修道院长，她是一个令人震惊的反犹主义者。牧师是一个令人钦佩的人物。农夫同样是一个非常接近基督的人。所以他似乎尊重这三者。但他明白，那种范式不足以解释他所处社会的复杂性。他是个伦敦人。他见证了社会是多么复杂。他也有个人经验，知道试图将传统的、老式的等级制度强加于社会是行不通的。所以在第一集中，我们谈到了《劳工法》。
Yes, trying to regulate labour and wages after the Black Death. Yes, introduced in 1351. And this is very important as an explanation for what, since the late 19th century, has been a very, very notorious episode in the life of Chaucer. So in 1873, documents were found that pointed to a case that had been brought against Chaucer by a guy called Thomas Staundon in 1379. And it recorded an agreement, what was called a quit claim, by a woman called Cecily Champagne. And Cecily agreed not to sue Chaucer over a case of what, in legal Latin, was referred to as a raptus. And a raptus can be translated as a rape. And so ever since then, there's been this kind of shadow over Chaucer's reputation. Was he a rapist?
是的，试图在黑死病之后规范劳动力和工资。是的，1351年引入的。这对于解释自19世纪末以来乔叟生平中一个非常、非常臭名昭著的事件非常重要。1873年，人们发现了一些文件，指向1379年一个叫托马斯·斯汤顿（Thomas Staundon）的人对乔叟提起的诉讼。它记录了一份协议，即所谓的“放弃索赔权”，由一个叫塞西莉·香槟（Cecily Champagne）的女人签署。塞西莉同意不再就法律拉丁语中被称为“raptus”的案件起诉乔叟。“raptus”可以翻译为强奸。所以从那时起，乔叟的名声就蒙上了一层阴影。他是个强奸犯吗？
Is this what the court case was about? But a couple of years ago, documents were found that showed that actually what the raptus referred to was a case that had been brought under the statute of laborers. Because Thomas Staunton, it turns out that had been brought under the statute of laborers because thomas staunton it turns out had been the employer of cecily and chaucer had offered her higher wages to work for him oh right and the quick claim cecily's quick claim basically i'm quoting here the scholars who discover the document offered the most expedient legal path under the statute of laborers for both chaucer andagne to demonstrate that she had left her employment with Staunton voluntarily, as opposed to being coerced or abducted before commencing work for Chaucer. So in other words, phew, Chaucer isn't
这就是法庭案件的内容吗？但几年前，人们发现了一些文件，显示“raptus”实际上是指根据《劳工法》提起的案件。因为托马斯·斯汤顿，事实证明，他是塞西莉的雇主，而乔叟曾向她提供更高的工资让她为自己工作。哦，原来如此。那份放弃索赔权，塞西莉的放弃索赔权，基本上——我在这里引用发现该文件的学者的话——为乔叟和塞西莉提供了《劳工法》下最权宜的法律途径，以证明她是自愿离开斯汤顿的雇佣，而不是在开始为乔叟工作之前被胁迫或绑架。换句话说，呼，乔叟不是
a rapist. He is a guy who is leaning into social and economic change, who is frustrating the statute of labourers, who is basically taking advantage of the fact that society has become much more mobile, and if you're a conservative, much more chaotic. I think you can look at the Canterbury Tales and see it as a kind of literary equivalent of what Chaucer is doing there, a refusal to be bound by a literary equivalent to the statute of labourers. So when the knight has finished telling his tale, the host turns to the person that the reader would expect, which is a figure from the church, because if you had a man who fights, then you expect to have a man who prays. So the host turns to the monk, but he gets interrupted. He gets interrupted by a miller. And the miller is
一个强奸犯。他是一个顺应社会和经济变革的人，他挫败了《劳工法》，他基本上利用了社会变得更加流动，而且如果你是一个保守派，社会变得更加混乱的事实。我认为你可以看看《坎特伯雷故事集》，把它看作是乔叟在那里所做之事的文学等价物，一种拒绝被文学版的《劳工法》所束缚的行为。所以当骑士讲完他的故事后，旅店主人转向了读者所期望的那个人，也就是教会的一位人物，因为如果你有一个作战的人，那么你期望有一个祈祷的人。所以旅店主人转向了僧侣，但他被一个磨坊主打断了。而磨坊主是
pissed. He's vulgar. He's low class. He's absolutely not the kind of person who should be following a knight and who should be interrupting a monk. But he's so drunk and he's so determined that he just carries on with his tale. And the miller's tale- It's very famous. Yeah. Very famous. Very famous. And the miller's tale famously quoted by Procol Horum in A White Shade of Pale, is very, very rude. Yeah. So there's a lot of... Buttocks.
喝醉了。他很粗俗。他属于底层阶级。他绝对不是那种应该跟在骑士后面，或者应该打断僧侣说话的人。但他喝得太醉了，而且非常固执，所以他径直讲起了他的故事。而磨坊主的故事——非常出名。是的。非常出名。非常出名。磨坊主的故事，普洛柯哈伦（Procol Harum）在《苍白的浅影》（A Whiter Shade of Pale）中引用过，非常、非常粗俗。是的。所以有很多……屁股。
People kissing arses, farting, buttocks being branded, all this kind of thing. It's the story that basically, if you do the Canterbury Tales at school, you hope this is the one the teacher's going to choose, and they never do. Because it is funny. Yeah. Definitely funny. But in its essentials, it's basically the same as The Knight's Tale. It's the same plot because The Knight's Tale had been all about two men competing for a lady. And The Miller's Tale is essentially the same.
人们亲吻屁股、放屁、屁股被烙印，所有这些事情。这基本上就是如果你在学校读《坎特伯雷故事集》，你希望老师选这一篇，但他们从不选。因为它确实很有趣。是的。绝对有趣。但从本质上讲，它和《骑士的故事》基本一样。情节是一样的，因为《骑士的故事》讲的是两个男人为一个女人竞争。而《磨坊主的故事》本质上也是一样的。
And The Miller says that he is quieting the knight. So he's paying the knight back. And this is very disruptive. Right. You know, in the wake of the Great Rev revolt and the social turbulence of the age. I mean, it's a very, very bold thing for Chaucer to be doing. And from that point on, the hierarchy is completely disrupted. So the pilgrims are not bound by the traditional social classes. Not only do you have millers, you have merchant, a cook, a shipman, you have a lawyer, you have
磨坊主说他是在回敬骑士。所以他是在报复骑士。这非常有破坏性。没错。你知道，在农民起义和那个时代的社会动荡之后。我的意思是，这对乔叟来说是一件非常、非常大胆的事情。从那时起，等级制度就被彻底打破了。所以朝圣者们不再受传统社会阶级的束缚。不仅有磨坊主，还有商人、厨师、船夫、律师，还有
various people from London guilds, you have a doctor, you have a yeoman who comes galloping up. All kinds of things are happening all the time. And I think that there is one of the pilgrims more than any other who embodies that sense of upheaval and novelty and I guess newfangledness, again, to use that Chaucerian word yeah and that's probably the most famous of all the pilgrims and that's the wife of Bath all right so the wife of Bath how many times has she been married five times she's been married five times and she tells the pilgrims that she's looking for a sixth husband terrifying describe her to the to the listeners Tom so she's very handsome.
来自伦敦行会的各种人，有医生，还有一个骑马赶来的自耕农。各种事情一直在发生。我认为有一位朝圣者比其他任何人都更能体现那种剧变、新奇，或者我再次使用那个乔叟式的词——“新潮”。是的，那可能是所有朝圣者中最出名的一位，那就是巴斯妇人（Wife of Bath）。好吧，那么巴斯妇人，她结过多少次婚？五次。她结过五次婚，而且她告诉朝圣者们她正在寻找第六任丈夫。太可怕了。汤姆，给听众描述一下她。她长得很漂亮。
She's very rosy-cheeked, although Chaucer specifies that she has a gap tooth. She's very broad-hipped. She wears bright red stockings. Scandalous. So very striking figure. She's a clothmaker. Yeah.
她脸颊红润，尽管乔叟特别提到她有牙缝。她臀部很宽。她穿着鲜红色的长袜。真丢人。所以是一个非常引人注目的形象。她是个织布工。是的。
She is rich enough that she's a serial pilgrim. So she's been to Rome. She's been to Santiago de la Compostela. so those are the two great pilgrimage sites in Europe, and she's been to Jerusalem three times. Was it possible for people to have gone multiple times to Jerusalem? Yes, it's not beyond the bounds of possibility. But it would be very expensive, surely? Very expensive, yes. So the wife of Bath is clearly quite a woman. Yeah.
她足够富有，以至于她是个连环朝圣者。她去过罗马。她去过圣地亚哥-德孔波斯特拉。那是欧洲两个伟大的朝圣地，她还去过耶路撒冷三次。人们多次去耶路撒冷是有可能的吗？是的，并非不可能。但这肯定很贵吧？非常贵，是的。所以巴斯妇人显然是个了不起的女人。是的。
And she tells a tremendous tale, which is about rape. This is why the idea that Chaucer himself was a rapist is so unsettling because the wife of Bath is a very, very, I think it's not too anachronistic to use the word, a very feminist figure. So her story is about a knight who has committed a rape. He's a rapist. He is threatened with execution. He's at the court of King Arthur, but Gwynevere intervenes and says that if he can find out what it is that women most desire within a set period of time, then he will be spared execution. The knight goes around trying to find it, can't find it. Then he meets a very ugly old woman who tells him the answer. The answer is that what women most desire is
她讲了一个非常棒的故事，是关于强奸的。这就是为什么乔叟本人是强奸犯的想法如此令人不安，因为巴斯妇人是一个非常、非常——我认为使用这个词并不算时代错误——非常具有女性主义色彩的人物。所以她的故事是关于一个骑士强奸了一个女人。他是个强奸犯。他面临死刑的威胁。他在亚瑟王的宫廷里，但桂妮薇儿（Gwynevere）介入并说，如果他能在规定时间内找出女人最渴望的是什么，那么他就可以免于死刑。骑士到处寻找答案，找不到。然后他遇到了一个非常丑陋的老太婆，她告诉了他答案。答案是女人最渴望的是
sovereignty over their husbands. And the price she demands for revealing this is that the knight will marry her. And so the knight thinks, oh God, I've got to. So on their wedding night, they go to bed and the knight is appalled that he's in bed with this ugly old woman. And she's very upset. And she ends up offering him a choice. She says that he's in bed with this ugly old woman and she's very upset and she ends up offering him a choice she says that he can choose she has kind of magical powers he can choose to have an old and ugly wife who will be true and loyal to him so in other words she will remain as she is or she will change and become very very beautiful very youth, but she won't be faithful. So which would he rather have? And the knight kind of ponders it. And then he says, I can't decide. You decide. And his wife
对丈夫的统治权。她要求揭示这个答案的代价是骑士必须娶她。所以骑士想，天哪，我必须这么做。所以在他们的新婚之夜，他们上床了，骑士对和这个丑陋的老太婆同床感到震惊。她非常难过。最后她给了他一个选择。她说他可以——她有一种魔法——他可以选择要一个忠诚但丑陋的老婆，换句话说，她会保持原样；或者她会改变，变得非常、非常美丽、年轻，但她不会忠诚。那么他更想要哪一个呢？骑士思考了一下。然后他说，我无法决定。你来决定吧。而他的妻子
is so delighted that he has surrendered sovereignty to her that she allows him to have his cake and eat it. So she turns into this kind of beautiful young woman and she's very faithful. So there you go. So this is the story that the wife of Bath tells. But the thing that makes it one of the greatest, greatest pieces of writing in the whole of English is the prologue. So the introduction to it, where the wife of Bath speaks in her own voice at twice the length that she devotes to her story. In here, she's telling the story of the five husbands that she's married. And on the one hand, she's kind of cheerfully admitting all the tricks that she's employed to kind of bend them to her will. But at the same time, she's
非常高兴他把统治权交给了她，以至于她让他两全其美。所以她变成了一个美丽的年轻女人，而且非常忠诚。所以就是这样。这就是巴斯妇人讲的故事。但使它成为整个英语文学中最伟大作品之一的原因是序言。也就是对它的介绍，巴斯妇人以她自己的声音说话，篇幅是她故事本身的两倍。在这里，她讲述了她嫁过的五个丈夫的故事。一方面，她兴高采烈地承认了她用来让他们屈服于自己意志的所有伎俩。但与此同时，她
describing the domestic abuse that several of them have inflicted on her. So who would suppose the woe that in my heart was and pain. So that's, you know, you see into the kind of the depths of her misery when she's suffering abuse. But at the same time, she's very, very rebellious, witty, larger than life, celebrating sex, refusing to be cowed by the fact that she's kind of getting on in life and absolutely contemptuous of the arguments that men traditionally present saying that women should be subordinate to men and that wives should be subordinate to husbands. And she is kind of making the point, which is one that's absolute standard
描述了其中几个人对她施加的家庭暴力。所以“谁能想到我心中的悲伤和痛苦”。所以，你知道，当你看到她遭受虐待时，你能看到她痛苦的深处。但与此同时，她非常、非常叛逆、机智、充满活力，赞美性，拒绝因为自己年纪渐长而感到畏缩，并且绝对蔑视男人传统上提出的认为女性应该从属于男人的论点。她正在提出一个观点，这在现在的女性主义理论中是绝对的标准
now in feminist theory, that men can write misogynist texts because they're men. And because in the Middle Ages and back into late antiquity, her husbands are always quoting the church fathers and she's saying, well, they would say that, they're men. Yeah, of course. Exactly. Yeah. If lions were writing it, they would write it about lions. And again, to quote Marian Turner, who wrote a wonderful biography of the wife of Bath, she says of the wife of Bath that she is the first ordinary woman in English literature. By that, I mean the first mercantile, working, sexually active woman, not a virginal princess or queen, not a nun, a witch, not a damsel in distress, nor a functional servant character, not an allegory. Right. But a living, breathing flesh and blood woman with agency and with
男人可以写厌女文本，因为他们是男人。而且因为在中世纪和古代晚期，她的丈夫们总是引用教会神父的话，而她说，好吧，他们当然会那么说，他们是男人。是的，当然。完全正确。是的。如果狮子在写，他们会写关于狮子的。再次引用玛丽安·特纳（Marian Turner）的话，她写了一本关于巴斯妇人的精彩传记，她说巴斯妇人是英国文学中第一个普通女性。我的意思是，第一个经商、工作、有性生活的女性，而不是处女公主或女王，不是修女、女巫，不是落难少女，也不是功能性的仆人角色，不是寓言。没错。而是一个有血有肉、有能动性、有
desires and anxieties and all these things of her own i mean she's basically chaucer's full staff yeah and marion turner in her book suggests that actually she's a direct influence on full staff so she she is a literary figure but like so much in chaucer's poetry she tells us a lot about what is convulsive about society in England in the wake of the Black Death. Right. So why is she a wife of Bath? Well, Marian Turner in her book points out that there is a lot of cloth manufacturing going on around Bath. Bath is near the Cotswolds, the wool trade, the booming kind of wool villages and towns.
欲望和焦虑的活生生的女人。我的意思是，她基本上就是乔叟的福斯塔夫（Falstaff）。是的，玛丽安·特纳在她的书中暗示，实际上她对福斯塔夫有直接影响。所以她是一个文学人物，但就像乔叟诗歌中的许多东西一样，她告诉了我们很多关于黑死病后英国社会令人痉挛的事情。没错。那么她为什么叫巴斯妇人？嗯，玛丽安·特纳在她的书中指出，巴斯周围有很多布料制造业。巴斯靠近科茨沃尔德（Cotswolds），羊毛贸易，蓬勃发展的羊毛村庄和城镇。
Absolutely. Yeah. So Tom, somebody listening to or reading the story in the 14th century, they would immediately say, oh, rich. Yeah. You know, an area where there's a lot of social economic change. Yeah. It's kind of, you know, it's like she's a tech entrepreneur, I guess would be the equivalent for us.
绝对是。是的。所以汤姆，在14世纪听到或读到这个故事的人，他们会立刻说，哦，富有。你知道，一个社会经济发生巨大变化的地方。是的。这就像她是科技创业者，我想这对我们来说是等价的。
She's someone who is in a hot spot of the economy and one that explains how she's as rich as she is. And it's not surprising that she's a woman because what has also happened in the wake of the Black Death is that it has accentuated trends, not just within England, but across much of Northern Europe, say Flanders as well and Germany and Scandinavia, in which women can increasingly choose who they want to marry. They're maybe having fewer children compared, say, to women in the Mediterranean, and they can marry repeatedly. And this gains them capital,
她是处于经济热点地区的人，这解释了她为什么如此富有。而且她是个女人并不奇怪，因为黑死病之后发生的事情也加剧了这种趋势，不仅在英国，而且在北欧大部分地区，比如佛兰德斯、德国和斯堪的纳维亚，女性可以越来越多地选择她们想嫁给谁。与地中海地区的女性相比，她们可能生孩子较少，而且可以多次结婚。这为她们赢得了资本，
which they can then kind of invest in things like, say, cloth manufacturer. And probably more women are involved in the economy in this period, in England, in the Netherlands, whatever, in the lowlands, than anywhere else in the world. They probably are exercising higher standards of numeracy, higher standards of literacy. So again, to quote Marian Turner, there is widespread agreement that in the second half of the 14th century, many English women had more choices and more autonomy than they had at other points in history or in other places. So the wife of Bath, her feminism is something that Chaucer is not inventing. Clearly, he recognizes that it's an expression of something that is distinctive about the society in which he's living. And the whole emphasis on the wife of Bath, she's a serial person who's
然后她们可以将其投资到布料制造等行业。而且在这个时期，在英国、荷兰、低地国家，参与经济活动的女性可能比世界上任何地方都多。她们可能拥有更高的算术水平和识字水平。所以再次引用玛丽安·特纳的话，人们普遍认为，在14世纪下半叶，许多英国女性比历史上其他时期或在其他地方拥有更多的选择和自主权。所以巴斯妇人的女性主义并不是乔叟发明的。显然，他认识到这是他所处社会中某种独特事物的表达。而对巴斯妇人的整个强调，她是一个连环
marrying. This is a trend in England at this time. The idea that widows marry is very, very disapproved by the church fathers. And this is what the wife of Bath is always complaining about. She's all in favor of it. And just as the church fathers cite scripture saying it's a sin, she cites and often misquotes scripture to say it's absolutely brilliant, absolutely fine. And what women can do in this period is that they marry very young. So 12 is when you basically, as a girl, you kind of enter the marriage economy. And girls will often be married to husbands who are much older than them. So The Merchant's Tale also is about this. It's about a very elderly man marrying a very young girl. And that means the husbands die.
结婚的人。这是当时英国的一种趋势。寡妇再婚的想法非常、非常受到教会神父的反对。而这正是巴斯妇人一直在抱怨的。她非常赞成。正如教会神父引用经文说这是罪一样，她引用并经常误引经文说这绝对是极好的，绝对没问题。在这个时期，女性可以做的是她们很早就结婚。所以12岁时，作为一个女孩，你就进入了婚姻经济。女孩通常会嫁给比她们大得多的丈夫。所以《商人的故事》也是关于这个的。它是关于一个非常老的老人娶了一个非常年轻的女孩。这意味着丈夫会死。
The girl, she'd be quite young. She pockets a lot of the inheritance. So under the common law, widow can keep a third of the husband's property for life. And if your husband's dead when you're 18, you marry again. He dies, you're 25. And so it goes on. You can accrue quite a lot of property. So you build your fortune. Yeah. And this is particularly true of women who are involved in trade. So in London, a widow inherits the marital home for life. That's not the case under the common law, but it is for merchants in London. And in London, a widow can keep a third of all the movable goods that a husband has, again, for life. So it's possible for women to end up very, very wealthy. And the wife of Bath is, in that sense, the embodiment of that cultural trend.
女孩，她还很年轻。她会把大部分遗产装进腰包。根据普通法，寡妇可以终身保留丈夫三分之一的财产。如果你的丈夫在你18岁时去世，你再婚。他死了，你25岁。就这样继续下去。你可以积累相当多的财产。所以你建立了自己的财富。是的。这对于参与贸易的女性尤其如此。在伦敦，寡妇可以终身继承婚房。根据普通法情况并非如此，但对于伦敦的商人来说是这样。在伦敦，寡妇可以终身保留丈夫所有动产的三分之一。所以女性最终变得非常、非常富有是有可能的。而巴斯妇人在某种意义上就是这种文化趋势的化身。
And there is a real life example that parallels the wife of Bath that illustrates just how wealthy a woman could become by remarrying. And that is none other than Chaucer's own granddaughter. That's Alice, right? Yes. So Chaucer dies in 1400, shortly after Henry IV has come to the throne. And of course, Chaucer, he's been a loyal associate of John of Gaunt. So he survived Richard II's reign. And now that Henry has become king, probably the last poem that Chaucer writes is a poem asking him for a bit of money. He's done amazingly well for a person of his social background, but not as well as his granddaughter Alice does. So by the age of 24,
有一个现实生活中的例子可以与巴斯妇人相媲美，说明一个女人通过再婚可以变得多么富有。那就是乔叟自己的孙女。那是爱丽丝（Alice），对吧？是的。乔叟于1400年去世，就在亨利四世即位后不久。当然，乔叟是冈特的约翰（John of Gaunt）的忠实伙伴。所以他在理查二世的统治下幸存了下来。现在亨利成了国王，乔叟写的最后一首诗可能就是请求他给点钱。对于他这种社会背景的人来说，他做得非常出色，但没有他的孙女爱丽丝做得好。到24岁时，
she's twice widowed, and both of them have left her with a lot of money. And she then goes on to marry William de la Pole, who will in due course become the Duke of Suffolk and who is the grandson of the Michael de la Pole, who was the Chancellor under Richard II and got attainted. Right. Who we talked about last time. Yeah. Wow. Right. So the Duke of Suffolk himself, the one that Alice has married, he also gets attainted and actually gets executed. But Alice keeps hold of all his lands and property. And she remains a widow for 25 years and she speculates and she increases her wealth. And she basically becomes one of the richest people in the whole kingdom, hugely respected,
她已经两次丧偶，而且两人都给她留下了很多钱。然后她嫁给了威廉·德拉波尔（William de la Pole），他后来成为了萨福克公爵，他是理查二世时期被剥夺公民权的迈克尔·德拉波尔（Michael de la Pole）的孙子。没错。我们上次谈到过他。是的。哇。没错。所以萨福克公爵本人，爱丽丝嫁的那个人，他也遭到了剥夺公民权，实际上被处决了。但爱丽丝保留了他所有的土地和财产。她守寡了25年，她进行投机，增加了她的财富。她基本上成为了整个王国最富有的人之一，受到极大的尊重，
massive, massive operator. And amazingly, her son, john de la pole ends up marrying elizabeth of york who is the younger sister of edward the fourth and richard the third yeah so she is the aunt of the princes in the tower right and she has a son yes and her son tom so the son of elizabeth of york and john de la pole this is very confusing that would make him chaucer's great great grandson he's also called john de la pole he is and he becomes the heir to richard the third so in 1484 yes richard the third names this john de la pole yeah cha-great-grandson, as his heir, which is incredible. And of course, Richard III gets defeated by Henry VII, who marries Elizabeth of York's niece, also called Elizabeth, very confusing.
一个非常、非常厉害的操盘手。令人惊讶的是，她的儿子约翰·德拉波尔（John de la Pole）最终娶了约克的伊丽莎白（Elizabeth of York），她是爱德华四世和理查三世的妹妹。是的，所以她是塔中王子们的姑姑。没错。她有一个儿子。是的，她的儿子汤姆，也就是约克的伊丽莎白和约翰·德拉波尔的儿子，这非常令人困惑，那会使他成为乔叟的玄孙。他也叫约翰·德拉波尔。他是，而且他成为了理查三世的继承人。所以在1484年，是的，理查三世任命这个约翰·德拉波尔，乔叟的玄孙，为他的继承人，这太不可思议了。当然，理查三世被亨利七世击败，亨利七世娶了约克的伊丽莎白的侄女，也叫伊丽莎白，非常令人困惑。
And John de la Pole never ends up becoming king, but he's still very much on the scene. And two years after the Battle of Bosworth in 1487, Lambert Simnel, raising the banner of rebellion, John de la Pole is there and he dies at the Battle of Stoke, which Henry VII wins against Lambert Simnel. But I mean, amazing, amazing that Chaucer's heirs are that close to the throne. So Chaucer's great-great-grandson could have been king. Could have been king. Yeah.
约翰·德拉波尔最终没能成为国王，但他仍然非常活跃。在1487年博斯沃思战役（Battle of Bosworth）两年后，兰伯特·西姆内尔（Lambert Simnel）举起叛乱旗帜，约翰·德拉波尔就在那里，他在亨利七世战胜兰伯特·西姆内尔的斯托克战役（Battle of Stoke）中阵亡了。但我的意思是，乔叟的后代离王位那么近，真是太神奇了。所以乔叟的玄孙本可以成为国王。本可以成为国王。是的。
Crikey. That's not bad for him. What was Chaucer's great-grandson or something? Of a pub landlord been king. Yeah. Crikey. That's not bad for... What was Chaucer, the great-grandson or something of a... Of a pub landlord, of Al Murray. That's amazing. Yeah. So I think that, I mean, Chaucer's life is fascinating as an illustration of the social turbulence of the age and of just how far people could rise. And it's not surprising that Chaucer himself, who's so socially mobile, should have been so interested in that as a theme. Of course, there's a sense in which that aspect of him gets buried because he very rapidly becomes the father of English literature, this great patriarchal figure.
天哪。对他来说这还不错。乔叟的曾孙还是什么的，竟然是酒馆老板的后代，本可以成为国王。是的。天哪。这还不错……乔叟是……酒馆老板的曾孙，阿尔·默里（Al Murray）。这太神奇了。是的。所以我认为，我的意思是，乔叟的一生作为那个时代社会动荡的例证，以及人们可以上升到多高，是非常迷人的。乔叟本人如此具有社会流动性，以至于他对这个主题如此感兴趣，这并不奇怪。当然，在某种意义上，他那一部分被掩盖了，因为他很快就成为了英国文学之父，这个伟大的父权形象。
Canterbury Tales gets famously printed by Caxton, one of the first books to be printed in England. He's the first English writer to have a complete works. So that happens in Henry VIII. And then the end of the 16th century, his tomb. So he's not buried in Westminster Abbey because he's a poet. He's buried in Westminster Abbey as a mark of respect from the monks who he'd associated with. But he gets put in a kind of improved tomb that suits his stature as the father of English literature. And Tom, we did say we're not the rest is literature, but he is the father of English literature, isn't he? did say we're not the rest is literature, but he is the father of English literature, isn't he? Because it's not just what he does with the language, inventing
《坎特伯雷故事集》被卡克斯顿（Caxton）著名地印刷出来，是英国最早印刷的书籍之一。他是第一个拥有全集的英国作家。这发生在亨利八世时期。然后是16世纪末，他的墓。所以他不是因为是诗人而被埋在威斯敏斯特教堂。他是作为对他所交往的僧侣的尊重而被埋在威斯敏斯特教堂的。但他被安置在一个符合他作为英国文学之父地位的改进后的墓中。汤姆，我们确实说过我们不是“其余皆文学”，但他确实是英国文学之父，不是吗？因为这不仅仅是他对语言所做的事情，发明了
all these words and phrases that we are so familiar with today, but he creates a way of writing, which as you said, is panoramic, is often very funny, is earthy, is sort of rooted in the concrete everyday realities of English life that so many writers, I mean, Shakespeare and Dickens would be two obvious examples, have kind of picked up. I mean, I'm not saying it's impossible that they would have done what they did without Chaucer, but Chaucer absolutely stands at the center of that tradition, doesn't he? He does. And I think his achievement is so great that it legitimizes for his literary heirs the idea that writing in English can be as prestigious as writing in Latin or French. So all the great poetry of the 16th and 17th centuries would kind of be unthinkable,
我们今天非常熟悉的这些词汇和短语，而且他创造了一种写作方式，正如你所说，是全景式的，通常非常有趣，接地气，植根于英国生活的具体日常现实中，许多作家，我的意思是，莎士比亚和狄更斯是两个明显的例子，都从中汲取了灵感。我的意思是，我不是说没有乔叟他们就不可能做他们所做的事，但乔叟绝对站在那个传统的中心，不是吗？他确实如此。我认为他的成就如此之大，以至于他向他的文学继承人证明了用英语写作可以像用拉丁语或法语写作一样享有盛誉。所以16和17世纪所有伟大的诗歌，如果没有乔叟的灵感，都是不可想象的。
really, without Chaucer's inspiration. And the other purely literary way in which Chaucer is massively influential is that because he's writing in the London dialect, it cements the sense of Southeastern English as being, I mean, not received pronunciation, but being the model that various other English dialects will start to be shaped by over the course of the 15th and 16th centuries. And so purely as a literary figure, I mean, he's the first great writer of the language that has become the global lingua franca. And he's a poet who, I mean, I know we've kind of made a joke about how he's impossible to understand, but actually he's not that hard to understand. He doesn't take that much of an effort and he is a great great poet whose achievements as i said i found them you know they gave me kind of great comfort and distraction in the first weeks of the lockdown yeah so i'm very happy to have done him
真的。乔叟产生巨大影响的另一个纯文学方式是，因为他用伦敦方言写作，它巩固了东南英语作为——我的意思是，不是公认发音，而是作为各种其他英语方言在15和16世纪开始被塑造的模型的地位。所以纯粹作为一个文学人物，我的意思是，他是已经成为全球通用语的语言的第一位伟大作家。他是一位诗人，我的意思是，我知道我们开玩笑说他有多难懂，但实际上他并不难懂。他不需要付出太多的努力，他是一位伟大、伟大的诗人，他的成就，正如我所说，我发现它们，你知道，在封锁的最初几周给了我极大的安慰和消遣。是的，所以我很高兴研究了他。
but i think you can also justify doing an episode of the rest is history on chaucer because he's so fascinating as a window onto the events that we've been describing. Right. Brilliant. Well, thank you, Tom. That was, it was not just a tour de force, actually. It was a tour d'horizon of medieval England. Now, the good news for listeners who've enjoyed this is that we are going to pause now,
但我认为你也可以证明在《其余皆历史》（The Rest Is History）中做一期关于乔叟的节目是合理的，因为他作为我们一直在描述的事件的窗口是如此迷人。没错。精彩。好吧，谢谢你，汤姆。那不仅是一次杰作，实际上，那是对中世纪英国的一次全景式考察。现在，对于喜欢这一期的听众来说，好消息是我们现在要暂停一下，
as we often like to do, but we will be returning later in the year, won't we, to this period, and you'll be taking up the story of what happens next. Henry IV, parts one and two. And Henry V and Agincourt. And one of the most evil characters in history, Joan of Arc, will be making her debut on the rest of history.
正如我们经常喜欢做的那样，但我们会在今年晚些时候回到这个时期，不是吗？你将继续讲述接下来发生的故事。亨利四世，第一部分和第二部分。还有亨利五世和阿金库尔战役。历史上最邪恶的人物之一，圣女贞德，将会在《其余皆历史》中首次亮相。
And the good news for those of you who didn't enjoy this is that actually next week we'll be doing something different. But I don't believe such people exist, Tom, because everybody will have enjoyed this. There will definitely be no Middle English in the next episode. Oh, that is disappointing. So, on that bombshell, believe such people exist, Tom, because everybody will have enjoyed this. There will definitely be no Middle English in the next episode. Oh, that is disappointing. So on that bombshell,
对于那些不喜欢这一期的人来说，好消息是下周我们将做一些不同的事情。但我相信这样的人不存在，汤姆，因为每个人都会喜欢这一期的。下一集中绝对不会有中古英语。哦，那太令人失望了。所以，带着这个重磅炸弹，
thank you very much, Tom. Thank you, everybody. And we'll see you next week. Bye bye. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host
非常感谢你，汤姆。谢谢大家。我们下周见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持
The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《其余皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。